chacun josé garcia lé costa gavras
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
[Musique]
ça va
en tous les cas le chauffeur de salle
est bon mais chauffeur est excellent
sinon attention la maison pour 1 devant
un spécialiste en ont vraiment un
accueil extraordinaire très bon
chauffeur de sphère publique
exceptionnelle
bien alors ça fait une semaine qu'on
vous voit tous les deux tel pipo et
dario font du cinéma et des magazines
dans toutes les radios dans toutes les
télés pour présenter votre nouveau film
le couperet avec karin viard ulrich
tukur alors qu'elle a été l'émission la
plus agréable mais celle ci quelle a été
la plus efficace à votre avis un plan
promotionnel mais celle-ci j'imagine
dans le pit c'est très simple en fait
c'est un chômeur qui est au bout du
rouleau et qui décide de repérer les
concurrents susceptibles de lui disputer
le poste qu'il vise pour les tuer un
voilà c'est extrêmement fort
il devient donc un serial-killer tout en
continuant d'ailleurs à mener une
existence tout à fait paisible avec sa
famille sa femme qui est jouée par karin
viard et ses deux enfants est une espèce
de conte amoral une femme une métaphore
sur le monde moderne qu'on tire que
faites vous pousser à bout l'idée quoi
c'est à dire qu'on dit toujours dans les
entreprises suis là je vais le tuer sauf
que là il tue vraiment quoi en fait
c'est ça l'histoire quoi c'est c'est
l'ultra libéralisme dans toute sa
splendeur c'est ça mais c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment fort c'est vrai il est
bon un garcia très bon un très beau
texte que je n'avais eu des bons acteurs
dans votre vie quand même c'est vrai ce
n'est pas déçu ça va tout content quand
il est content alors on va voir à quoi
ça ressemble vous allez regarder tous
les de votre caméra et vous allez dire
magnéto serge sûrement pas on va pas
t'aider sur ce coup là
dessus tu les prends en main il ya la
rébellion la wii à se laisser faire
comme ça ça va être beaucoup plus dur
serge suite au maintien non non c'est
jamais et d'autre des sittings c'est la
première fois que des invités veulent
pas dire magnéto serge des gens ne
connais pas ce monsieur donc de savoir
qui tu es un gars qui porte à un nom de
film célèbre monsieur club il paraît
vous êtes croiser à l'aéroport
tiens donc mais si oui ce fameux serge
la wii ralala voyous comme pas deux
halak a bien non c'est con ces concerts
j'allais bien la bande annonce laisse
aller où les cabines mais l'hymne qui
pourraient accompagner monsieur en régie
je crois qu'il faut que ça s'arrange il
faut que ça s'arrange entre
[Applaudissements]
comment ça se passe vous ennuyer pas
avec lui ça va et les photos il est
sympathique c'est comme ça sans arrive
parce que vous passez une quinzaine
formidable vaut plus que plus ce
vieillard une rue à sens et c'est
formidable car j'en profite d'ailleurs
pour dire qu'elle est excellente et les
formidables mais celle des grands
acteurs randall triglycérides et bon
acteur en france en ce moment là d'une
bande de jeunes acteurs qui sont très
bons la l'huile un potentiel
extraordinaire
il est sérieux en plus ibos bon il
arrive en régie la haye série a live ça
y est un jury les rizières l'hiver
regarde rit oui serge il veut se faire
sauter avec la régie
on s'en fout oui annoncé de l'acier vous
êtes habillé ici on est trois ans chez
les plus anciens
donc le premier jus qu'il faut ce que
vous voyez bien vous avez l'expérience
et c'est moi qui coûte le plus cher
ce moment j'ai un boulot si je perds mon
boulot quant au bureau je ne tire aucune
prudence y trompe pas relatif l'oeuvre
est et pourquoi vous tirez pas ils nous
prennent au citron d'un des deux autres
présentés -
[Musique]
vous vous laissez pas tenter un pouvoir
jubilatoire à lire les secrets de mes
concurrents se découvrait qu'il vivait
dans une ignorance abyssale
certains arbustes et la vanité on
sentait que nous avait appris à rédiger
des cv ça pue le conformisme y avait que
5 qui diplôme et carrière et surtout
expérience me paraissait sinon meilleurs
mais aussi bon que moi une idée
vertigineuse m'est venue
[Musique]
voilà le couperet de costa gavras avec
josé garcia cahill
olivier gourmet qu eric tout court
alors que ça gavras
après z l'aveu est à kiev missing amène
et plein d'autres vous êtes toujours
finalement dans un cinéma militant quoi
vos films veulent dire quelque chose je
pense que beaucoup des cinéastes nous
sommes inspirés de ce qui se passe dans
notre société
alors là on attend je suis j'ai
découvert cette histoire qui me
permettait de parler de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui dans une société avec et il
est évident que c'est que fait josé
c'est à dire toutes ces tueries savent
c'est vraiment une exagération ce qui
est vrai c'est ce qui se passe à côté
parce que parce que notre société
commence à vivre c'est que l'amérique
comme un service où il ya une vingtaine
ou trentaine d'années c'est-à-dire le
libéralisme ne vous parliez tout à
l'heure de jeu 6 1 litres a dû oublier
un peu l'homme et y met en avant l' eee
l'économie à la place de l'homme
mais si oui ce n'est pas l'économie
c'est la finance rcnm plus absolu
dimension économique succès les
actionnaires qui dirige les sociétés
s'est laissé les les retraités qui sont
floride les fonds de pension et
finalement pour les satisfaire on
délocalise et c'est ce qui arrive aux
personnages qui est jouée par josé quoi
que tu es un mec qui est bon c'est pas
sympa loser pas rater c'est un type qui
est très haut dans la société c'est pas
un moment on le vire quoi ils excellent
dans son boulot il est très bon père de
famille zen mec formidable
et puis on a donné idei il y des gens un
peu parce qu'il dit voilà je ne peux pas
avoir un bon travail et il fait sa
guerre il le fait pour sa famille ou sa
famille et pousse à tous sa vie où sa
maman elle était destinée
il est comme beaucoup de gens à qui on
qui ont organisé leur vie autour de
salaire mais les ou ce salaire se perd
tout commence à se défaire et il paye sa
maison à tempérament d'accueil au risque
de la perdre
elle n'a pas pour dix ans et la maison
exactement donc d'art à quelques mois
n'a il risque de ne plus devoir la payer
et la période complètement
il n'a plus les mêmes moyens pouvaient
tous les jours il peut parler du steak
tous les jouets des pâtes
voilà des pâtes et ainsi de suite et la
famille commence à se défaire aussi en
même temps bravo je sais merci alors
votre légende que nous avions commencé à
établir ici quand vous êtes venus
finalement aujourd'hui c'est devenu une
partie de l'histoire du cinéma parce que
j'avais commencé à raconter un peu vos
devis et puis là je vois que maintenant
les télés létale toute la journée
vos vos parents gens de maison votre bep
raté l'armée à 17 ans et demi
les galères 12 ans avant parce que nous
on l'a connu à une perte avant une paire
il a capté 12 ans de deux petites
compagnies théâtrales et après ça
c'était le bon côté ouais ouais c'est la
légende de josé garcia et puis le succès
populaire comique avec la vérité si je
mens et jet set
et puis nos grands films voilà le grand
film ça c'est du pot parce que tous les
tous les comics tous les gens comme ça
on leur dit toujours quand est ce que tu
vas faire ton tchao pantin c'est michaël
youn dont on nous rabat les oreilles
avec ça la chance que vous avez vu c'est
de faire un
finalement un personnage sérieux avec un
réalisateur classe quoi ouais ça c'est
ça c'est laid le sublime cadeau et c'est
extraordinaire
il y avait eu le film de philippe harel
extension du domaine de la lutte où déjà
il y avait ça en filigrane quoi alors
c'est vrai que les comics on attend
toujours qu'il fasse la leurs grands
films sérieux
toi aussi tu le feras un jour j'ai fait
il ya finalement tuer josé garcia pour
coluche et tchao pantin et bourvil
il ya eu fernandel et eurent émis en fin
juillet le plein plein d'acteurs
comiques et un jour sont passés dans le
film sérieux et finalement ils font des
îles font les meilleurs drame les comics
dont certains rythmes ils ont ils ont
d'abord une sympathie formidable euros
de sympathie du public qui est important
mais aussi je pense qu'ils ont le rythme
le rythme que beaucoup d'autres acteurs
non pas vraiment parce que le comique
demandé un travail énorme c'est le genre
le plus difficile que même alors vous
vous travaillez comme un faux nom prenez
sacrées au sérieux a avoué bien sûr est
ce que vous prenez pas ça un peu trop au
sérieux
je me dis quand je vous vois vous est
excellent mais je me dis il manque
peut-être un peu de légèreté des fois
parce que vous n'êtes qu'un genre alors
la vie je parle pas à l'écran
je crois que le travail c'est de faire
les choses sérieusement mais aussi avec
un petit peu de légèreté de créer des
moments il faut il faut vous savez à
chaque fois qu'on a un film qui sort
c'est vrai que vous essayer des trucs
dedans quelquefois vous prenez des gros
taquets quoi elle se voit devant vous
êtes devant tout le monde toute façon ça
soit je sais que quand je fais avec
d'autres acteurs surtout en comédie on
commence on s'assoit au regard des gens
on s'installe et puis on descend des
centres et s'en tient aux faits d'avancé
puisque la tête sous le truc qu'on
voyait jamais personne donc c'est très
délicat mais j'imagine que tous mes
confrères vous en demandez si vous vous
turier pour prendre la place d'un acteur
vous avez dû répondre pour jouer faut
être deux et moi ce que j'aime c'est le
partage non mais voilà vous avez lu pas
mal de trucs là car j'aimerais ça c'est
que bon c'est ce que j'aurais répondu
aussi vous et des réponses comme ça vous
faites d'émission en émission
un démission démission non mais c'est
vrai qu'au bout d'un moment quand on a
fait la promo provins et tout ça il ya
aussi des en tout cas une façon
d'agencer les phrases qui vient
généralement dans le bon sens oui dans
le même sens ils savent bien casse
couilles au bout d'un moment non ça
vient pas casse couille parce qu'en fait
les gens découvrent à chaque fois il
vous pose la question ils ont
l'impression de la poser pour la
première abbas et ça donc il faut leur
répondre comme d'accord mais il faut
quelques mètres d'accord c'est mon
boulot bon financièrement ça va super
bien je vais vous étiez le neuvième
revenus du cinéma français oui il me
reste encore huit activée
ça va venir ben rhodes
alors devant lui voilà il ya jean reno
depardieu michaël youn christian clavier
gérard jugnot thierry lhermitte daniel
auteuil
catherine deneuve voilà j'aime ex-aequo
avec isabelle huppert
ouais tu y en a qui sont pas jeunes
maintenant oui non mais bon on va pas
besoin de les tuer en même temps en même
temps ces dégâts établi non média jeune
gars qui sont arrivés devant c'est ça
qui ont doublé dans le virage 1 c'est
pas bien
alors josé voilà maintenant vous êtes un
vrai acteur dans des vrais films sérieux
avec costa gavras et tout c'est plus de
la rigolade maintenant c'est cool j'ai
vu les rues ou dans l'autre sens j'ai vu
et on va faire une interview grands
acteurs alors josé garcia maintenant
vous êtes un grand acteur est ce que
vous allez refusé de parler de votre vie
d'avant à nos jours sûrement pas de voix
soit une colle au cul je peux rien y
faire à ça et je voulais dire gérard
pour parler de depardieu
non moi je dirais gg est ce que vous
allez nous faire payer en liquide pour
aller dans des soirées grâce à
j'aimerais bien mais j'ai pas trouvé le
filon ça fait des années que je cherche
deux fils ont d'ailleurs je fais une
annonce à ses les petites soirées un peu
poivre qu'est-ce qui leur mallette de
cash je suis partant avec un portable
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous avez refusé de parler de
votre vie privée parce que tu comprends
c'est privé quoi oui oui la vie privée
s'est privée mais parce que je dis voilà
est-ce que je vais commencer toutes vos
phrases par personnellement ce que
j'aime dans le cinéma adore ça je ne
pourrai jamais ça me fera zag poelvoorde
on s'est toujours marrer en disant il ya
une phrase qui surtout aux césars qui
peut vraiment se mettre dans le mur
c'est le cinéma c'est le juste derrière
va écraser tranquillement c'est super
dur de non et puis moi toute façon en
cinq minutes j'ai toujours une photo de
moi bien en gros c'est donc je suis
renvoyé de starship si on vous voilà
est-ce que vous allez porter des
lunettes noires la nuit ah si je suis
bourré il ya aucune raison que je ne le
mettrais bien évidemment et des chapeaux
de mémère est ce que vous allez vous
faire offrir tous vos vêtements ma
langue est un grand acteur aurait mais
cela aussi je laisse à mon sens le bon
filon d'accord vous avez quitté votre
femme
ah non non non non c'est normalement
quand on réussit on quitte non oui non
mais ça serait duo là ça serait quand
même c'est comme me couper une jambe
d'appui
vous allez recevoir des scénarios avant
gérard lanvin maintenant surtout pas
j'ai pas envie de me faire péter la
gueule
est ce que quand vous voulez dîner
tranquillement vous avez réservé toutes
les tables de restaurants maintenant non
vous savez il suffit que j'arrive
j'arrive avec un ami belge est au bout
de cinq minutes l'étape sans voix
il ment et tous le voir allume trop de
sa soeur est ce que j'allais appeler
scorsese faut dire que son dernier film
pas mal ce qui choque le numéro pourquoi
pas on pourra s'amuser un samedi soir
est-ce que vous allez comparer la taille
de votre limousine avec celle d'un autre
acteur salue vos chaussures en smart
alors si je commençais à mesure pour
vous la taille c'est pas important
bah disons que je fais avec vous avez
exigé une doublure pour les scènes de nu
ah non je ne fais pas de scènes de nu et
puis si je pouvais m'offrir une doublure
ça serait très drôle mais en parlant
avec goal est blond généralement c'est
un moment vous êtes torse nu dans le
film
ah oui peut-être de marrakech très haut
un braquet non circuit en petit en
densité et c'est vrai que la caméra ça
grossit fait de la muscu un petit peu
ouais ça se bat il m'arrive aussi
d'aller dans des amas
est-ce que vous allez demander de l'eau
minérale pour vous laver les cheveux un
enfant de la bière c'est très bon la
levure
ça se voit oui je sais ce que j'ai dit
oui à des films sans lire le scénario
juste en lisant de chèques non mais ça
pourrait m'arriver si j'étais vraiment
dans la panade
oui maintenant vous êtes un grand acteur
est ce que vous avez refusé de revenir
dans cette émission
ah non non non pas maintenant que je
fais un grand acteur je peux venir à
souhait voilà je peux quand vous voulez
karim
et
on
alors la mine
il ya un nouveau truc dans cette
émission c'est la carte
magique attention quand je prends une
carte une poche
10h10 les habitudes du poker et oui eh
ben moi je dis 50 et toi qu'est ce que
cela car ton tu faisais et ben faut
mettre 50
je sus nationale car je double je vais
porter un grand chapeau à paris
c'est ce critère
[Applaudissements]
c'est truqué
c'est
[Musique]
dans un terrain vague je dois faire un
film sérieux depuis des années s'est
engagé à gauche c'est bon de mime
[Musique]
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu